bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous sur l
défense à la deuxième vague est là et
elle est violente c'est ce qu'a déclaré
le premier ministre cette semaine les
chiffres de contamination ne cesse
d'augmenter ce que vous leur santé dans
votre cabinet oui on ne ressent à tous
les niveaux on ressent en amont des
hospitalisations dans nos cabinets de
ville où l'activité est en croissance de
40 à 50% par rapport à une activité à la
même période les années antérieures
nous n'avons encore pas toutes les
pathologies autonome d'alger hivernale
donc pour l'instant oui c'est très très
très important et les hospitalisations
qui en découlent et les cas graves faits
relevant de la réanimation également il
ya une grosse grosse épidémie sur notre
secteur ligériens et stéphane la gestion
des malades vu que v l'escale se fait au
détriment des autres malades on entend
parler d'un grand nombre d'opérations
qui sont des programmes et notamment
dans les hôpitaux est ce qu'on est en
train de créer un autre problème le
problème du printemps était que nous
avions un besoin
devant cette première vague inconnu
d'organisation et de nécessité de soins
pour les patients atteints du coc vite
de déprogrammer beaucoup d'opérations
beaucoup de soin on s'est rendu compte
après dans le courant de l'été que
c'était une perte de chance énorme pour
les patients sur un plan de chirurgie
cardiaque cancérologique urologique et
tout soin qu'on pouvait apporter à ses
patients et du coup le but était de
déprogrammer initialement le moins
possible les opérations c'est pour ça
que les hôpitaux les réanimations
cumulait des soins traditionnels
postopératoire opératoire classique
hospitalisation classique
en parallèle du début de l'épidémie
qu'ovide nous voulions maintenir cette
activité pour que les patients et toutes
les chances de se faire soigner sur les
autres pathologies quelques vides et
puis malheureusement le besoin se fait
ressentir le besoin de place le besoin
de nez de déprogrammer devenu impératif
il est laissé à l'appréciation de chaque
médecin chaque chirurgien pour les
patients pour ne pas perdre tous les
patients et qu'on puisse quand même
garder une activité autre que le coc
vide dans certains domaines de la
médecine la deuxième vague et elle est
bien là elle est allée bottle est ce que
vous êtes favorable à un renforcement du
confinement actuelle mon avis médicaux
médecins me direz oui bien évidemment
puisque nous je vous parlerai simplement
mon secteur et de ma région nous sommes
la région la plus touchée de france je
suis à dix kilomètres de la ville la
plus touchée de france dans un secteur
et un bassin de population nous sommes à
+ 33 % de positivité des tests contre
une moyenne nationale à 22 23 % depuis
quinze jours que saint-etienne métropole
est passé en confinement
je n'ai pas l'impression qu'il y ait
réellement une baisse d'incidence sur
cette épidémie qu'ovide et oui je pense
qu'un renforcement des mesures peut-être
pas nationale mais sur certaines régions
certains secteurs va devenir rapidement
un impératif
le pic épidémique n'est encore pas
atteint nous l'annoncions pour
mi-novembre apparemment il va être
décalé de quelques jours donc ça nous
pousse encore jusqu'à fin novembre et
d'ici là les hôpitaux seront en piste
les réanimations se remplissent la
médecine de ville fait tout ce qu'elle
peut pour effectivement prendre en
charge les patients également ne
relevant pas d'un split alisation et
pouvant être maintenus à domicile en
surveillance mais oui ce pic est très
très très important alors en dépit du
confinement certaines enquêtes révèlent
que les français continuent de se
déplacer
est-ce qu'il faut imposer le télétravail
ça fait partie deux choses sont parties
malheureusement des schémas de
contamination vous avez le monde du
travail dans l'entreprise alors on a
beaucoup parlé du temps de pause
méridien avec les restaurations ou
effectivement c'était un un moyen de
contamination nous avons également toute
la jeunesse les lycéens et les étudiants
qui font effectivement partie de ces
modes de contamination
il n'y a pas de schéma idéal
effectivement mais oui favorisées comme
l'avait dit et rappelé encore madame la
ministre il ya 48 heures il favoriser le
télétravail le plus possible limiter les
contacts c'est ce qui nous permet en
respectant toutes les règles sanitaires
de d'éviter ce confinement généralisée
par secteur ou par région qui est malgré
tout très néfaste à tous niveaux
psychologiques physiques qui offre
malheureusement qui va faire une perte
de chance colossal pour les patients au
niveau de lancement et noir sentiers
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions yannick fraiser
vice-président de l'union des
professionnels de santé des médecins
libéraux d'auvergne et rhône alpes